but uh do you all know each other yeah
yeah we uh i i got invited to do a
little workout with lara hammond you
know larry hampton he's the 100-foot big
wave crazy surfer and he says uh hey i
saw him on the beach one time and he
goes hey come up and come work out with
me so i go to his house up in the
mountains you do that a lot y'all are
just like hey come work out with me
that's all we do that's it that's it
that's what we do so glad i'm a woman
right now
but he's got this um he's got this pool
and it's custom made for these workouts
these underwater workouts with weights
and so i go up there and i jump in the
pool and i see him coming out and he's
shredded and i'm like well this is a
pretty cool little workout uh and and i
start to do the workout and you're
underwater you're panicking and and
you're you can't breathe you're oh
you're not like doing it in your heads
above water you're underwater no you're
under one and they're laird you know he
serves 100 foot weight he's he's crazy
like he's like hey uh go do a workout
get underneath the water and then then
you're gonna go to the uh ice cold tub
which is just filled with ice and then
you're good for you and then from there
you go to a 180
degree sauna and you do a bike for 20
minutes and i'm like i almost died i was
like what did your heart do during this
yeah
but he does it all the time yeah but
what's great is you like you look at him
and you go no like this guy's going to
show up and he's going to control the
whole pool and he got there and he
started crying and
one of the worst things i ever did in my
life i was like oh my gosh
you did great you did great oh my god
this reminds me of one time they were
like my friends on a vacation like we're
gonna go on this beautiful hike and i
was like hell yeah let's do it it was
like fat camp from hell it was it was i
was i literally my stomach got upset i
was like oh my i was like it was the
worst experience of my life and i'm
don't that's why i don't work out
[Music]
you